to listen to the media in this country
you would think that these are the
biggest stories in America as the
fallout from Donald Trump's disastrous
summit with Vladimir Putin continues so
does the Muller investigation into
possible Trump Russia collusion there
seem to be some sort of expense system
in place the Trump for an organization
for things that needed to be fixed like
a stormy Daniels that conversation with
Donald Trump that Michael Cohen secretly
recorded is officially no longer a
secret I think the big story here is the
fact that you now have Michael Cohen has
now flipped on Donald Trump but those
stories are nothing more than
meaningless stand-ins distractions from
the most important story of the day now
what is it
America's winning again because we have
a president with guts on defense on
manufacturing our culture trade few
presidents have fought the way Trump has
even his former GOP foes have had to
concede the obvious
here's Marco Rubio on Trump's
interactions with China and a broader
scale I don't know of any administration
that's confronted China's cheating more
than this administration has to be fair
Trump has steadfastly refused to cede
America's preeminence to the communist
regime of China but remember China
already has a 23 point two trillion
dollar economy which is almost 4
trillion more than our own but with
tough tariffs and blunt talk he has now
brought China to the negotiating table
that is a very good thing and just today
the president met with EU Commission
president to discuss trade after Trump
boosted tariffs on certain EU goods to
create a fair situation for American
manufacturers the EU retaliated with
tariffs of its own but today they were
all singing a different tune we agreed
today first of all to work together
toward zero tariffs zero non-tariff
barriers and zero subsidies on non auto
industrial goods we will also work to
reduce barriers and increase trade and
services chemicals pharmaceuticals
medical products as well as soybeans
that will also make trade fairer and
more reciprocal when I was invited but
President to the White House I had one
intention I had the intention to make a
deal today and we made a deal today why
didn't any of these other presidents
done what Trump did they didn't want to
or they didn't have the brain power to
do it or they didn't have the courage to
do it but today the market responded
closing at its highest level since
January and this kind of advance
wouldn't have been possible if Trump had
not raised the issue and raised the ante
with EU all along the market is soaring
wages are beginning ever so slowly to
rise in fact two hundred and thirteen
thousand jobs have been added here just
last month due to Trump's policies GDP
growth is strong with an expected huge
number this Friday bottom line it is a
great time to be an American someone is
working who wants a job and to top it
all off the president's higher American
initiative has started to produce
results
there was a 41% increase in denials of
high-skilled h-1b visa applicants
between the third and fourth quarter
that helps American citizens over
foreign workers in the job market it's
about time and the president is doing
all of this while battling the deep
state the unfair media of course all the
international bureaucrats we've come to
know and love and establishment
politicians here in Washington and there
are some congressmen who despite all
this great news just refused to get the
memo that the Bush era is over I don't
support tariffs I think tariffs are
taxes and I think there are better tools
that we can use to hold abusers of trade
laws and people who countries that
perpetuate unfair trade practices I
think there are better tools to use to
get them to play fairly I have a
question if there's magic tools are out
there
why wouldn't they use before but
tools of look at the toolbox where are
they let's remember what some other
experts in Congress were recently saying
about the tariffs a wildly swung bat
that is hitting our closest allies in a
way that harms our national security
harms our chances of better trade deals
I just think there's so much collateral
damage I think it's a very risky and
dangerous strategy this is an abuse of
presidential authority just it's an
abuse of presidential authority
well once again guess what they're wrong
Trump stood for America with a tool that
every president is used in one form or
another and our economic competitors
ended up doing the thing that he
predicted that do they came to the table
they started listening and they made
concessions more are coming by the way
so rather than taking potshots at the
president Republicans should be
celebrating and promoting this approach
to trade in the economy the Trump agenda
it's also their clearest path to victory
in the midterms
which reminds me by the way a word of
caution for this president at the same
time we got to talk straight here with
all the good news also a word of caution
every time mr. president you comment on
the latest Michael Cohen tape or every
time you spar with lowlifes like Brennan
or avenatti or any of them I think what
you do sometimes you end up giving
oxygen to the stories advance by your
political opponents to distract from the
most important story that's America's
economic resurgence and the restoration
of our place in the world so Donald
Trump should be taking a victory lap
almost every week in a different way
shape or form
things are awesome right now the more
the president is party focus on that
story the more the stormy Muller Michael
Cohen sideshow is diminished the media
attempt to distract voters from the
lived experience of the Trump economy
but I'm telling you it's not working my
radio listeners tell me every day we
don't care about these stories what's in
my bottom line
Trump's approval by the way today at
forty eight percent according to a new
Arkan barometer poll the voters know
reality and they're tuning out the rest
of this stuff it's kind of white noise
background noise to them they can see
the impact of this presidency everyday
they can feel it their pocketbooks they
can feel it in their lives and that's
the angle